that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk and i'm dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
jonathan is going to be taking us
through some of the museum's collection
of desert eagles and telling us what
makes this high caliber handgun so
unique even the barrel is a deadly
weapon
if you like this kind of content please
make sure to subscribe as we have
episodes of load up going up every
sunday and you can already check out our
previous episodes on shotguns the m1
garand and the mythical silver sword on
top of that we'll still be showing
jonathan new gaming arsenals every
saturday so make sure to check those out
too first up let's hear jonathan explain
why the desi eagle is so big
apart from the sheer size of the desert
eagle
i think the thing that makes it well the
thing that makes it technically
interesting and
as far as i know unique is that it has
essentially the the gas system of a
rifle
if you open the thing up you'll see
a multiple lugs rotating bolt like
something from an ar 18 or something and
if you peek really closely inside you'll
actually see a piston not too far away
from kalashnikov for example it's just a
lot smaller this is partly why the gun
is so damn huge because it has to
accommodate this rifle type locking and
cycling mechanism it doesn't necessarily
give it its iconic lines that's more of
a stylistic thing it's
famous for being gigantic and blocky and
that is partly dictated by its
mechanical design
now let's see jonathan break down the
unique interior of the desert eagle so
we know the desert eagle is big
and wildly heavy at least that's what a
lot of games and movies show us but
jonathan is actually going to try and
illustrate that with the little
selection here so can you walk us
through what makes this thing such a bit
of a beast to wield well with us for
scale i think you can get an idea of
that so if we grab the mark one
we do have an original mark one desert
eagle here i mean just i don't have huge
hands but i've got quite long fingers
and you can just see
this thing is immense you know it puts a
glock or a beretta to shame quite
frankly and the physical weight of it i
mean
it is
i i fired one when i was in america and
especially 50 action express is also for
pistol caliber heavy so adding that into
the magazine in my experience shooting
in america
i never really thought that i was going
to
break anything until i fired desert
eagle i thought
yeah i am gonna
put that one down for the next time i
think i prefer something a little more
low-caliber but the weight is immense my
hands
you know they looked
comedically childlike
when holding a desert eagle yeah i mean
it's difficult to get um demonstrate
vaguely the
the classic modern two-handed shooting
grip that's the most stable and gives
you the best grip you know you're
supposed to not be able to see a gap
between your hands when you hold it and
i can just about do that because i have
quite
quite long fingers as i say but it's a
real it's literally a handful more than
a handful i mean look my my shooting
hand doesn't doesn't wrap around this
properly and that's just a function of
trying to contain the power of a magnum
pistol cartridge self-loading pistols
weren't designed originally to contain
that much muzzle energy essentially yeah
and
it only gets worse when the barrel gets
longer and you get a scope i mean this
just trying to hold that
is quite the strain i think if you if
you shot this at a hobby level or like
you said earlier hunting
you're gonna have forearms that are
pretty immense well that definitely
helps you know physical physical
strength will help you overcome the
practical
limitations of this but still you'd
still be better off with something
smaller high capacity as well because
you know it's a single stack magazine
you can only fit in
nine rounds of 357 750 action express
it's not it's not probably not the go-to
pistol for most people safe to say we
were talking earlier about what makes it
unique and there was something in the
internals that you wanted to show off
that is unique among the desert eagle
when it comes to handguns yep so why
don't you go and show us that i'll do my
best and it's not it's not so obvious
from the outside so if we take the
magazine off again
what we can do
pop off
the barrel
one way in which this is unusual is in
having this fixed barrel
if it's not fixed now because i've taken
it off but when you use it it is sits
there on the frame not moving making it
inherently more accurate than a pistol
with a tilting barrel that unlocks as it
comes back or a rotating barrel or any
of the other ways in which
pistols are locked shut so that they
work properly but that advantage is kind
of negated by just how unwieldy this
thing is and your sights are going to
wave around on target unless you've got
big strong forearms so just by popping
that off we can see the main features
that i'm talking about here so
there's that big
lugged bolt which is like nothing you'll
see on a conventional pistol it's much
more like what you'd see in a gas
operated rifle
and up front there sticking off the
front of the
the slide is the piston
there's a tiny piston but it's a gas
piston nonetheless complete with a sort
of
dished front
and so when this thing fires there is
actually
what we can't see a little port inside
there and then this is the sort of
inverse of the gas piston
which shoves backwards
and drives the slide
to the rear to operate
the gun
quite a unique beast then yeah and then
with the double recoil spring with their
own guide rods because it's got to then
shut the thing
coming forwards
there we are
even the barrel is a deadly weapon
the desert eagle may be enormous and
unwieldy but are there any advantages to
such a giant handgun there are
theoretical advantages to a gigantic
handgun unfortunately they're highly
theoretical so you are by increasing the
chamber pressure through that
gas-operated system by increasing the
diameter of the bullet to half an inch
and therefore the mass of the bullet
you are on the upper end of what a
pistol can deliver in terms of
energy on target however
you can't
make a handgun into a rifle
it's it's at the the sort of ragged edge
of what a handgun can do and as a result
of that is very big
very heavy the recoil is significant
it's not as much uh perceived recoil as
a revolver because you have moving bits
of metal that slow down the recoil but
still it's it's a lot of recoil to sort
of fire more than one shot rapidly and
accurately is a challenge and just
carrying the thing around unless you're
arnold schwarzenegger and have his his
hip thigh
and hand
as to whether wherever the gun is
situated
you're not going to do well you do not
see this thing in any practical context
thank you so much for watching this
episode of loadout if you enjoyed it
please do like the video and subscribe
and maybe even let me know in the
comment section down below or on twitter
at a regular dave what you'd like to see
an episode on if you want more video
game firearms content you can watch the
previous series of this show or check
out our weekly series of expert reacts
where i show our friends the royal
armory a slew of guns to break down
until next time i've been your host dave
dewitt thanks again for watching and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you